بدايه السؤال المطروح بالنسبه لكم ما هي
الاولويات الان
لرعايه هؤلاء الاطفال
الوضع هنا في
محافظات حيث ان الان حساس وخطر جدا لان
هناك العديد من الاسر التي تنام في
الخيام وتنفيذ درجات حراره تاخذ تحت الصفر
ليلا وان الاطفال الذين ماوى المهم انهم
الان بامان وهم غير معرضين
احوال الجويه وايضا تحدي الكبير الاخر هو
عدم وجود منشات صحيه واستكانيه استخدام
مياه صالحه للشرب بالنسبه للاطفال
قد دمرت تدميرا كاملا بحث ليس هناك
مرافق صحيه والناس يقضون حاجاتهم في
الشوارع وهناك خطر كبير انتقال لامراض
بسبب المياه الملوثه وبالتالي هذا سيؤثر
على الاطفال في الاطفال هم اكثر ضعفا في
امام هذه الامراض
الوضع على الارض فعلا تحدثنا عن بعض السر
هنا في هذه المناطق المتضرره من انطاكيا
وبعضهم قالوا ان اطفالهم لديهم حالات قيء
وسوء التدهور الصحه وبالتالي هناك حاجه
ضروريه لتقديم تقدير مدى احتياجاتهم
الصحيه كما هناك صعوبه كبيره اخرى وهي ان
هناك كثير من الاطفال الذين انفصلوا عن
اسرهم
ويصبحوا لوحدهم الان وهم طمعان تجري
رعايتهم عن طريق وزاره الاسره والشؤون
الاجتماعيه ونتعاون نحن معها هنا ولقد
تطلب الامر قبل اكتشافه واخراج جميع الجثث
من تحت الانقاض لكن حاليا من الصعب نعرف
كم من الاطفال فقد والديهم او من يعتني
بهم
غالبا حينما تقع كوارث من هذا النوع يتم
الحديث عن الدعم النفسي
كيف تتعاملون مع هذه القضيه الدعم النفسي
للاطفال
هذا فعلا الموضوع في غايه الاهميه لانقاذ
الاطفال وقد بدانا فورا منذ
نشاط الدعم الاجتماعي في في قطاي فيها
تاعي وودعنا بالتعامل مع الاطفال الذين قد
نجوا من الزلزال وقد لهم مكانات يمكن
يلعبوا فيها ويرسموا صورا وذا هذا مهم جدا
للاطفال ان التعبير عن ذواتهم وان يشعروا
نوع من الامور او الحياه اعتياديه بالنسبه
لهم وقد شاهدنا لبعض النشاطات والاطفال
يرسمون جثث ويصفون كيف خرجوا من الماء
وقفزوا من الشبابيك وكيف انه والديهم
كانوا يحاول انقاذهم هذه طبعا بين مدى
الصدمه التي تعرض لها هؤلاء الاطفال
وبالتالي من المهم لهم ان يعبروا عن
مشاعرهم هذه
ولكن طبعا الدعم والذي نقدوه نحو طلب وقتا
طويلا ولكن نواصل تقديم هذه المساحات
المخصصه للاطفال لكي يستطيع ان يحصلوا على
الدعم النفسي واخر ملاحظه هي انه طبعا
هناك مليونير لاجئ سوري في هذه المحافظه
التي تعرضت الى الزلزال والاطفال هنا
غالبا يكونوا اطفال سبق لهم اذا نزحوا عده
مرات من منازلهم الاصليه وبالتالي
فمشاكلهم معقده ومركبه وهذا ان هذا طبعا
ثم هناك صدمه الحرب التي مروا بها سابقا
وبالتالي نحن نشعل بقلق خاص نزاهه الاطفال
لذلك نحاول ان نزيد
استجابتنا وايضا فيما يتقدم بزياده نشاطات
الدعم النفسي شاهدنا اطفال
نجوا
نجوا انفسهم لوحدهم يعني بدون ابائهم
وامهاتهم وتم نقلهم الى اماكن امنه ذلك
اين يتم اياهم وكيف تتم الرعايه بهم الان
الاطفال
ضمن صلاحيات وزاره الاسره والشؤون
الاجتماعيه
وان السلطات هذه الوزاره تعتم الاطفال
الذين عزلوا على عوائلهم وهناك خط سائل في
بلاد منكم يستخدم الناس للبحث عن الاطفال
هؤلاء اطفال الذين يجوا تسجي تسجيلهم
الخدمات الاجتماعيه الحكوميه تعتني بهم
ويضعونهم في اماكن محميه وجيده طبعا لا
نستطيع ان نعتبر الاطفال على انهم ايتام
الى ان نتاكد من مصيره والديهم واقاربهم
بشكل مؤكد وشاهدتم الدمار الكبير هناك
الكثير من المباني المدمره بحث يتطلب
بالامر اسابيع بالاشهر لاخراج كل الجثث من
تحت الركام وتطلب امر وقتا طويلا لنعرف
بالضبط كما كم عدد من الاطفال ايتام ولكن
طبعا قلقنا
اول المواصله التعاون مع السلطات المحليه
لاهتمام بهؤلاء الاطفال وحمايتهم ووضعهم
في وضع امن رنده غازيه مديره الاعلام
الاقليمي لمنثاق الشرق الاوسط واوروبا
الشرقيه في منظمه انقذوا الاطفال متحدثه
من انطاكيا شكرا جزيلا لك